- What did we feed you that's
making you fart like this?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to hurt your
feelings, but it's true.
(barking)
I know, Bean, Games of Thrones isn't real
even though we all wish it was.
Oh, hello.
Is this hangout time?
We having a chat?
Beanie, you don't wanna sleep in your bed?
What, this isn't good enough for you?
Can you shut the door?
Is this what you wanted, Bean?
Yeah?
This what you, this what you like?
Do you think you'd hump
yourself if you could?
You ever think about how
you're not wearing any clothes?
Wearing a collar is like
the only clothing you have.
Dang.
Gettin' more action than I am.
I'm sorry.
That's rude.
When you get excited everyone can see it.
At least I have pants on.
I hear you.
(barking)
Thank you for protecting the house, Bean.
If ever a murderer came in
here, we would all be dead.
Okay, all right.
You're gonna be a party animal!
Look at you, you party, yeah, no.
I don't like hats either.
Bean, you are not a guard dog.
(barking)
You're not scary enough.
Can we just find a place
to sit and sit there?
Not, oh, okay.
Hit my crotch.
I'm afraid of thunder too.
Your haircuts cost more than mine do.
That's not right.
Bean, did you fart?
Oh, God, you little gross puppy.
I know it's scary, life is scary.
Just kidding, you're not gross!
You're not gross, you're adorable.
Oh, God, you are
actually quite smelly.
Quite smelly.
Gettin' some action, huh?
All the cuddles.
You're a good cuddler.
You're a good cuddler, Bean.
I can just snuggle up next to you.